journal rentrée politique de françois
mitterrand comme prévu ils appellent à
relancer l'union de la gauche sahara
occidental hassan ii plus modérée
vis-à-vis de l'algérie le reportage
exclusif de l'équipe dentelle chez les
paras mesdames et messieurs bonsoir on
pourrait presque résumer ce mois d'août
pas comme les autres une phrase
les températures sont sensiblement plus
basse que la normale mais les fruits du
et les légumes sont sensiblement plus
cher en huit jours pour le consommateur
dans la région parisienne
la laitue a augmenté de 150% sur
certains marchés en tout cas les
haricots et les poireaux vaudrait moitié
plus cher que la semaine dernière de
mazères pichot grimperait moins fort
mais il grimperait 30% de plus et le
melon aurait presque doublé
il y a là des questions que je voudrais
poser au ministre d'économie monsieur
mannarino fait d'habiter de sa présence
le consommateur n'y comprend rien il y
as malaise mais il n'ya pas que la
région parisienne bastia reportage de
fr3 bordeaux la valse des étiquettes
existe aussi en province même dans une
région de maraîchage comme le sud-ouest
sur un marché de la périphérie de
bordeaux ce matin la laitue se vendait 3
francs pièce contre 250 la semaine
dernière chez le mandataire un franc 50
en moyenne chez le producteur un franc
le melon 490 de 3 francs 84 francs 60 au
marché de gros de francs 50 chez le
producteur
il a grimpé de 1 franc en une semaine
les haricots verts extra-fins 12 franc
90 pour la ménagère 9 francs chez le
grossiste 7 francs 50 à 8 francs chez le
producteur qui est responsable de la
flambée des prix chacun se renvoie la
balle
d'autant plus qu'au mois d'août il est
plus difficile de faire coïncider
l'offre et la demande reste que c'est le
consommateur qui paie même s'il n'est
pas toujours très avisé par exemple
samedi dernier à bordeaux une barquette
de framboises coûté 12 francs le
commerçant en a vendu
48 acheté 5 francs aux producteurs
résultat les circuits de distribution
étant impénétrables
les vente directe du producteur au
consommateur se multiplient pour le
producteur plus de frais de commissions
15% plus de transport ni de
conditionnement et plus d'1 bondues qui
atteignent normalement 25 % par an pour
le consommateur enfin c'est parfois
l'assurance d'avoir des produits à
moitié prix chacun se renvoie la balle
on s'y perdrait demain nous essaierons
de remonter la filière
le pain lui avait monté à 20 des légumes
et les frissons prix avait été libéré en
78 et depuis lors il a augmenté selon
des catégories et selon les régions du
pays d'environ 20% sud mayenne on
pouvait penser que la libération des
prix signifierait concurrence et que le
consommateur on profiterait mais non
pour un seul et même pas c'est à peu
près le même prix partout comme l'a
constaté de visu à laurence graff
moi la pente et bagages
il a pris
vous avertit mme valu un prix
on m en cinq ans
il y a
dans les boulangeries du quartier du 7e
arrondissement la baguette est un franc
cinquante 20% de plus que l'été dernier
avant la libération des prix c'est une
hausse non négligeable puisque la
baguette représentent 50% des échevins
des parisiens mais ce qui est étonnant
c'est que d'une boulangerie à l'autre
les prix soient les mêmes
là vous vous trouvez tous la france 50
dans le quartier sans vous être entendu
je pense qu'on est tous d'un franc
cinquante dans le quartier je pense à
fond parce que mes collègues récupérer
je sais qu'ils vendent à 25 ans mais je
vous dirai pas qui on est tous là
préférant dans le quartier vous n'avez
reçu aucune consigne c'est tombé de sa
fille non en fait c'est à dire on essaye
de s'entendre encore en chocolat etc
c'est ta troupe qui est vraiment ne se
fit pas du voisin
voici mon collègue de l'évent d'un franc
70e rendre à françois 103 40
prix libre ou non pour les habitants de
ce quartier le prix de la baguette est
le même le problème c'est de savoir si
un arrangement de bon voisinage peut
être considérée comme une entente d
d'obèses inquiet de cette hausse de plus
de 20% du prix du pain maintenant est
comment peut-on faire pour mieux
contrôler les prix des fruits et légumes
c'est la question que je pose le seul
ministre eh bien tout d'abord jours et
vous répondre sur les fruits et légumes
parvis chaslerie l'information me
semble-t-il n'a pas été complète pour
les français on l'a mis en valeur depuis
48 heures l'augmentation de 3 produits
sur des prix relevés à rungis
on a oublié de prendre en même temps
d'où ce produit qui eux avaient beaucoup
baissé
je vous donne un exemple la pomme golden
se vendait l'année dernière au même
moment dans la même dizaine dans la même
semaine 3 francs 60 et aujourd'hui de
francs et je vous citerai comme ça une
douzaine de productions dans le même cas
et je vais vous donner à mon avis ce qui
est le juge de pêche en seconde ne pas
contester lundi ce car celui ci est fait
par des techniciens les scientifiques et
jusqu'à présent personne de la contester
et bien entre le 1er juillet 1978 le 1er
juillet 1979 les fruits et légumes ont
augmenté de 8 7% ce qui est une
augmentation légèrement inférieure à
l'augmentation du coût de la vie alors
de tous les deux tout temps et tous les
ans au mois d'août
vous avez eu malheureusement des
perturbations sur tel ou tel produit
pourquoi d'abord parce que le 15 ou
tombe un mercredi qu'il y a parfois une
déstabilisation des approvisionnements
parce qu'un centre de commerçants arrive
vers le le lundi ou le mardi après le 15
août et ouvrent leurs magasins à se
précipite sur le marché pour
s'approvisionner
donc vous aurez dans une commune marché
des fluctuations relativement important
d'un jour à l'autre mais il faudra faire
la politique de la france au jour le
jour
il faut faire la politique sur une
période beaucoup plus longue et je le
répète les fruits et légumes ont
augmenté d'une année sur l'autre de 8 7%
et je dirais même que sur deux ans les
légumes ont augmenté de 1 % parce qu'il
souffre que l'année dernière le marché
était très déprimé alors je crois que il
y avait bien sûr quelques abus je crois
que l'immense l'immense majorité des
commerçants des détaillants est en
général une majorité très honnête il
peut y avoir quelques abus j'ai fait
procéder d'ailleurs au co ces derniers
jours mille vérification je me suis
aperçu d'ailleurs fait la région
parisienne qui était la moins sage c'est
toujours
comme ça la région parisienne est une
très forte concentration humaine ou peu
de magasins sont ouverts périgourdine et
ya 10% d'infractions qui vont être
immédiatement sanctionné parce que vous
le savez les fruits et légumes et la
distribution n'est pas libre pour fixer
ses prix puis sioniste il ya plusieurs
syndicats notamment et fo qui réclame un
contrôle voire même un blocage des prix
alors à ce que les derniers mouvements
vous avez constaté sur les prix vont
vous amener à ralentir votre politique
de libération les prix écoutez j'ai dit
et je répète que depuis toujours la
libération des prix industriels était la
priorité du gouverneur par industrielle
industrie en ce qui concerne les
commerces
alors je vous répondre alors l'homme la
liberté des prix industriels s'est passé
très bien puisqu'en un an et depuis la
libération les prix ont évolué
sensiblement comme l'année précédente à
0 50% prêt en ce qui concerne les
services et la distribution j'ai
toujours dit que les libertés
interviendrez lorsque les consommateurs
auraient fait un peu plus de de dialogue
en effet un peu rugueux aurait eu un peu
plus de conversations avec les
distributeurs les prestataires de
services
c'est ce qui est en cours actuellement
mais certains qu'il faut que les
mentalités évoluent il faut prendre que
les consommateurs que les syndicats et
je remercie monsieur bergeron d'avoir
posé la question parce qu'il peut être
très utile avec le syndicat fo il faut
informer les consommateurs il faut les
habituer à avoir un comportement
différent
les habitués à voir un réflexe ne pas
aller chez celui qui a trop augmenté
mais il n'est pas qu'ils allaient lancer
notre campagne d'information des
conseillers y aura des campagnes en
permanence nous avons renforcé les
moyens des organisations de
consommateurs et nous les renforceront
encore c'est à dire que nous multiplions
par quatre leurs moyens en deux ans qui
est j'apprenais musicale ronnie
notamment que le que les effectifs de
des cervidés contre les prix ont baissé
ou alors les effectifs de contrôler les
prix n'ont pas baissé ils baisseront il
a été programmé dans le temps au fur et
à mesure que les libertés interviendront
une légère diminution des effectifs
pour l'instant tous les effectifs sont
en place et ceci se fera très
progressivement et tant que le liront
pas plus vite dans la liberté des prix
et bien je pense que les effectifs
baisseront pas en parallèle mais le
régime mais ce que l'on peut continuer
monsieur nice a libéré les prix en
bloquant des salaires
écoutez toute façon je le dis je le
répète l'économie française ne pouvait
trouver complètement son expression son
dynamisme que dans la liberté
j'ai dit et je répète qu'en ce qui le
concerne la liberté des services et de
la distribution nous n'étions pas
pressés et dans ces conditions nous
allons à nouveau dialoguer réfléchir et
et ceci à qui reviendra progressivement
mais rien ne presse pour le reste ce qui
était important c'était l'industrie
revenant au pain monsieur le ministre
quel est votre opinion sur l'évolution
des prix bien mon opinion tout d'abord
je crois que le pain je ne veux pas du
tout excuser les boulangers car j'aurai
l'occasion de dire ce que je pense mais
je crois que le pain il faut le ramener
au seuil et sa juste proportion le pain
n'est pas l'élément essentiel de
l'économie française il représente
malheureusement dans le budget des
ménages quelque chose de très faibles il
ya beaucoup de boulangers qui sont bien
comportés dans mon département
un journal la nouvelle république a fait
une enquête sur l'évolution du prix du
pain c'est de l'ordre de 10 à 12% et
d'autres départements voisins sont dans
le même cas
les fortes progressions sont en gueule
encore dans la région parisienne
vous avez vu tout à l'heure un franc
cinquante proment dans les régions
touristiques où il ya une toujours à
certaines saisons une concentration
humaine très forte et si nous relevons
nous allons y regardez comme nous
l'avons fait dans le passé des ententes
de syndicats ou entre boulanger nous
laissant que l'on sévèrement j'ai déjà
sanctionné huit syndicats départementaux
qui avait procédé d antan et nous allons
mettre sur un pied d'égalité
d'installation les tests et les
boulangeries industrielles avec les
boulangers artisanale les boulangers
s'il se comporte mal ils ont tort car il
donne l'occasion à des boulangers
industriels de prendre leur place et
probablement lorsqu'elles seront
installés de vendre à des prix
inférieurs aux boulangers artisanale et
à ce moment là les boulangers se
mordront les doigts d'avoir fait cette
erreur je crois qu'il faut qu'il soit
très prudent car dans l'avenir nous
sommes près tout à fait disposé à la
facilité c'est un plant associé me
depuis plusieurs jours on assiste quand
même pas mal de critiques à l'égard de
votre politique est celle du
gouvernement des critiques qui ne
viennent pas uniquement d'opposition et
syndicats mais qu'ils viennent de
journaux qui en général était assez
favorable la politique que vous menez
alors est ce que vous estimez que ces
critiques doit vous faire modifier du
moins sur certains plans la politique
conduite alors je peux vous dire que en
ce qui concerne la politique de liberté
les prix industriels
elle ne sera pas modifié il n'est pas du
tout question de revenir
en sur cette philosophie qui est
fondamental les français sont aussi
intelligents que les allemands les
allemands vivent dans ce système depuis
longtemps et on voit les résultats que
leur économie a connu résultats tout à
fait satisfaisants résultats qui a
permis à l'allemagne de se placer en
tête des pays développés eh bien nous ne
reviendrons pas sur cette politique une
liberté des prix industriels
je crois que ce serait l'erreur
fondamentale que pourraient commettre le
gouvernement nous recevons bien sûr des
critiques
ce qui m'intéresse et sera mon dernier
mot sur les prix ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que probablement au bout de sept
mois en régime de liberté depuis le
début de l'année au bout de sept mois
l'indicé global
reprenant tous les articles or a évolué
aux environs de 0 50 % plus vite que
l'année dernière quand on voit
l'environnement international on peut
considérer que c'est une performance
tout à fait de travailler une rentrée
difficile mais c'est le ministre avec
tout ce qui s est passé
écoutez je souhaite que les français
comprennent réfléchi ce qu'il y a des
problèmes extérieurs qui sont de non pas
du fait de la france mais qui sévissent
ces problèmes dans tous les pays
comparables au nôtre
je souhaite que les français fassent
preuve de beaucoup de compréhension
beaucoup de raisons c'est à nous de leur
expliquer je crois que sont exprimés à
la rentrée ne sera pas trop difficile
merci la rentrée politique de monsieur
mitterrand s'est faite elle à anglet
dans les pyrénées-atlantiques où comme
on s'y attendait le secrétaire général
du parti socialiste a relancé l'idée de
l'union de la gauche devant les
militants du ps réunis en stage monsieur
mitterrand a souligné que cette gauche
de salut public qu'il souhaitait ne se
ferait sans doute que pas à pas pour lui
il est indispensable d'organiser des
actions et d'engager des discussions
avec l'accord de toutes les forces de
gauche pour l'été contre la politique
actuelle du gouvernement une politique
qui selon monsieur mitterrand est un
échec total
le plus grand et le plus grave échec de
la politique française de l'après-guerre
échec dont il est facile de discerner
les causses facile de désigner les
responsables
c'est la juste rançon de la durée c'est
là justement son de la stabilité et le
premier d'entre ceux qui ont bénéficié
de cette durée conditions jugées jusqu
alors indispensable pour mener une
action politique dure et qui a trop
souvent manqué aux dirigeants des
républiques précédentes c'est bien
monsieur giscard d'estaing chacun sait
que l'expérience de monsieur bart a
échoué lui seul semble en douter
légèreté à l'elysée vanité à matignon
ainsi s'appelle l'attelage qui prétend
conduire la france condamnation de la
politique du gouvernement actuel puis
propositions pour l'union de la gauche
que cette union se fasse à la base au
sommet rélève comme celui de teyran
d'une querelle futile l'important est
d'être d'accord pour dialoguer et
ensuite agir que nous considérons que
aujourd'hui le rôle du parti socialiste
et d'appeler l'opinion à la seule
solution politique capable de répondre
sur un plan général et par là sur tous
les plans particuliers aux questions
posées
celui survie solution politique qui est
l'union des forces populaires le
rassemblement des forces économiques et
sociales
aujourd'hui dispersés l'élargissement
même de la base sociale des luttes au
delà peut-être des analyses
traditionnelles traduction politique de
cette union des forces populaires de cet
élargissement de nos basses
yann pour l'instant cela ne porte qu'un
nom que chacun salue avec révérence
qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui de rétablir
dans son ampleur l'union de la gauche
ira-t-on et oui lyon de la gauche alors
puisque les circonstances politiques ont
marqué le cran d'arrêt de cette union de
la gauche et pour ne pas se perdre dans
le vocabulaire l'union des forces de la
gauche union des forces sociales nous
n'avons passé d'autres analyses en 1971
le congrès de metz se situe dans la
ligne droite de du congrès d'epinay
étrangers la situation en iran évolue de
jour en jour la rébellion kurde
s'intensifie l'ensemble de l'armée
iranienne a été mise en état d' alerte
par ordre de l'ayatollah khomeini la
frontière entre la turquie et l'iran a
été fermé les cures de leur côté lancé
un appel à plusieurs chefs d'état des
pays étrangers à téhéran l'ayatollah
essaye mais pas souvent avec succès de
raffermir un pouvoir de jour en jour
plus chancelant malgré l'appel aux armes
contre les kurdes et l'opposition la
république islamique de l'ayatollah
khomeini se donne des allures de
démocratie monsieur base arguant le chef
du gouvernement réunissait hier la
première constituante qui doit rédiger
les futures institutions du pays 50 élus
sur 70 sont des religieux comme
l'ayatollah ali rahni un modéré qui
défendra sans doute le statut des
minorités
cette assemblée est donc un test
teste également l'attitude de l'armée à
qui lie à taux l'arménie a donné l'ordre
d'aller mater la rébellion kurde
il veut d'abord réhabiliter l'image de
ses soldats aux yeux de l'opinion car
ils ont tiré sur la foule lors de la
chute de l'ancien régime
redonner leur moral alarmés humilié par
la révolution et voir si elle obéit à
ses ordres
vous
mais pour cette bataille contre les
kurdes tous les soldats n'ont pas a
répondu présent le cambodge va-t-il
disparaître la carte du monde on peut se
demander avec angoisse
il y avait à bord et le régime des
khmers rouges dans les dirigeants
avaient organisé pendant des années un
véritable jeu incite aujourd'hui selon
les informations recueillies à bangkok
le vietnam aurait entrepris
l'élimination physique de la race khmer
les anciens fonctionnaires seraient
envoyés en rééducation au vietnam et
n'en reviendrait plus l'armée
vietnamienne ramasserait tout le riz en
échange de mauvaises farine et après me
rées penser les cambodgiens
même si tout cela était exagéré je viens
de parler au conditionnel on peut dire
que peu de peuples au monde ont souffert
autant depuis quelques années que les
cambodgiens
le roi du maroc hassan ii a tenu une
conférence de presse affaires affirmant
qu'il était prêt à aller jusqu'au bout
pour conserver le sahara occidental pour
lui juridiquement il n'y a pas de peuple
sahraoui mais allégeance normal des
habitants du sahara occidental envers un
sultan du maroc en somme en s'installant
le 10 août dans la partie du territoire
abandonné par la mauritanie a dirigé à
biya le maroc n'a fait qu'user de son
bon droit devant l'accord conclu cinq
jours plus tôt à alger entre le
polisario et la mauritanie accord que le
roi près de papier signé à l'issue d'un
pique nique au total le roi était plutôt
modéré à l'égard de l'algérie en
s'attachant à fait ressortir le rôle de
la libye qui dit il a tout intérêt à
soutenir le polisario au conflit éclata
entre maroc et l'algérie parce que le
président kadhafi ne rêve que d'une
chose c'est de prendre les personnes de
cette région
éclaté entre le maroc et l'algérie jeu
ce qui se passerait là je la libye
mettra à la disposition de l'algérie
tout son potentiel militaire y compris
d'énigmes l3 peut-être et l'autre pas
par des algériens ou des libyens mais y
compris ses mig 23 ou ce 10ème disons du
char où tout est rose
ce recueil on vraiment affaiblis
l'algérie et le maroc
quand notre ami le président pâtit se
trouverait epsp actes en disant avoir
payé comme d'habitude et impayés être le
avoir le leadership de l'afrique du nord
où il extrait d'une je sais si le
polisario lens ne va pas contribuer à
propos de base en mauritanie
est ce que vous avez fait le droit de
suite pas un instant tu contre l'algérie
n'a pas besoin de bouger ou facebook
je serai justement c'est une bd c'est un
des paradoxes
j'ai exposé au président henri d'allant
en lui disant vous allez nous mettre
dans une situation invivable sur le plan
humain pendant des heures mais trompons
vécu à côté des autres fraternellement
pendant deux ans nous avons aidé à vous
défendre pendant deux ans toutes les
garnisons dans laquelle nous étions leur
population civile était sous embargo
nous médecins soignent et ses
populations ce soir par hasard est
habile hongrie et j'en oublie d'autres
et je dis oui vous avez fait en sorte
que ces mêmes soldats qui détaille les
coûts étaient je peux être un tu écris
tu sois pas un soldats mauritaniens soit
atteint brille notamment des civils ça
l'a vraiment le drame de cette décision
politique parce que c'est
la fecq la débandade la déroute
politique mauritanienne mais que se
passe-t-il dans l'autre cas vous savez
que la semaine dernière
de très violents combats ont eu lieu
entre les sont marocaines et le front
polisario c'est à dire bernès arabe les
marocains ont subi des pertes sévères et
ils reconnaissent avoir perdu sans tom
en un seul engagement
bernard rapp et jean-françois renou
rentrer du sahara occidental où ils ont
passé quelques jours avec les
combattants du polisario
ils ont rencontré entre autres les
prisonniers mâles ces hommes que l'on
emmène dans le désert sont des
prisonniers marocains capturé par le
polisario
le plus ancien été pris en novembre 77
ils sont aujourd'hui plus de 400
derniers arrivés ces prisonniers tombée
aux mains des sahraouis le 11 août lors
de l'attaqué du poste marocain de bir
anzarane bilan de l'opération une
centaine de morts du côté marocain et
ses 175 prisonniers dont cinq officiers
c'était la première fois que le
polisario menaient une opération de
cette ampleur avec plus de 3000 hommes
selon les marocains l'opération avait un
double but frapper un grand coup au
moment où le maroc s'apprêtait à
contrôler une nouvelle zone du sahara
occidental et du même coup il s'agissait
de saper le moral d'une armée marocaine
qui a déjà payé un lourd tribut à cette
guerre du désert
de fait les positionner que nous avons
rencontrés pour autant qu'ils aient pu
parler sans arrière-pensée semblait
particulièrement amer j'ai vécu la
situation et j'ai tenu le coup jusqu'à
une minute on a réuni appris
d'artillerie ni appui et annie
interventions rien
la liaison radio a été cru a été propre
et tout le monde s'occupe seulement des
pc les soldats marocains sont très des
modalités parce que c'est une guerre qui
adorait qui a duré plus de cas de 4 ans
et marc mais mon bataillon a été depuis
le 3 mars 76 76 ça veut dire que le coup
tout le bataillon a été pratiquée par
les dans la vie dans les tranchées et
par les déplacements dans les zones dans
la zone qu'ils ne savaient pas et à deux
kilos mais 3 3 km
de la position qu'occupe le bataillon
personne ne pas s'orienter veut dire que
tout le monde tout le monde et
démoraliser l'armée sahraouie qui tient
un site est marocain et prend
aujourd'hui l'initiative a si bien
l'armé du désert organisé en unité
légère elle connaît admirablement le
terrain et sa mobilité peut être inouïe
pourtant si l'efficacité des combattants
sahraouis ne fait plus de doute
plusieurs mystères demeurent d'abord
combien sont ils ces soldats sahraouis
qui combattent si bien une question quel
le polisario oppose le secret militaire
autre mystère leur armement uniquement
des armes récupérées sur les militants
officiellement c'est en partie vrai tout
comme il est vrai que les derniers
combats n'ont pu se dérouler sans
l'utilisation d'armes plus sophistiqués
enfin dernier mystère où ses troupes
centre intel en algérie ou dans les
territoires libérés
une chose en tout cas est sûre ces
combattants par est aujourd'hui capable
de frapper l'armée marocaine où et quand
ils le désirent mais sans que l'on
puisse pour l'instant envisagé une
solution militaire décisive
le front polisario en est d'ailleurs
conscient et le ministre de l'intérieur
sahraoui est très clair lorsqu'il nous
reçoit
nous sommes prêts nous battre
explique-t-il mais nous ne faisons pas
la guerre pour la guerre notre but c'est
de forcer le maroc à négocier avec nous
et à reconnaître nos droits sur le
sahara occidental loi langage apaisant
donc coquelles péter qu'aucune activité
diplomatique d'une ampleur nouvelle
comme en témoigne le voyage d'étude d'un
représentant du congrès américain
stephen sommers
après rabat paris et nouakchott le voici
chez les sahraouis une mission
d'information bien sûr mais qu'on ne s'y
trompe pas malgré ses airs de vacanciers
en goguette
l'émissaire america c'est que le sénat
des états unis doivent bientôt se
prononcer sur de nouvelles livraisons
d'armes au maroc des livraisons dont on
pourrait bien retiré au dernier moment
certains matériels destinés à la guerre
du sahara
histoire de donner un coup de pouce à la
négociation il reste trois petites
survivante des octuplés nés jeudi à
naples
toutes les trois sont des fillettes si
du ghana à martin à leur état est encore
très grave et nous ont toujours des
difficultés respiratoires
mais on note une légère amélioration
énormément de quitter l'hôpital demain
ou après demain les cosmétiques lee
iacocca yumin ont atterri hier soir en
sibérie centrale kazakhstan après avoir
passé près de six mois en orbite autour
de la terre
c'est le record de durée pour les vols
spatiaux habités comme l'ont dit avant
d'entendre un savant français monsieur
lebon vice président de l'agencé
spatiale européenne nous expliquer ce
que l'on peut attendre sur le plan
scientifique d'une telle réussite
voyons comment les cosmonautes sont
revenus de leur long séjour dans le
vaisseau soyouz 30 15
un long voyage dans l'espace qui se
termine au bout d'un parachute doucement
tranquillement un retour dont
l'exactitude permet d'avoir ces belles
images
on est bien sûr les cosmonautes à sortir
de leurs capsules parce que leurs
muscles ont perdu l'habitude de vaincre
la pesanteur mais dans un mois tout sera
normal riou mines et yaakov n'ont pas
l'air très fatigué pourtant ils ont fait
un nombre d'expériences considérable à
bord de la station salliot de 6 il
faudra certainement de longues semaines
pour dépouiller toutes les informations
qu'ils ont recueillies en particulier
pour analyser des matériaux nouveaux
dont certaines expériences ont été
conçus avec des scientifiques français
leur retour a été retardée d'une semaine
à cause d'une antenne qui gênait
certaines manner et il leur a fallu
sortir de leurs engins pour la dégager
dans l'espace les plantes qu'ils avaient
emmené ne sont jamais venus à maturité
et en les voyant sentir c'est simple
marguerite
on peut penser que le plancher des
vaches doit avoir du bon pourtant la
présence de l'homme dans l'espace sera
de plus en plus courants comme nous
l'expliquent un spécialiste
et je crois parce qu'on peut en dire de
plus important c'est que la présence de
l'homme dans l'espace devient quelque
chose d'habituel et une époque dans les
années 1900 où elles ont compté les vols
des avions
maintenant il ya en l'air en permanence
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'hommes
et nous sommes en train d'entrer
progressivement dans une période où il
ya en permanence des hommes dans
l'espace
et ce que nous ne savons pas en fait
c'est combien dans 30 ans il y aura de
même occupé à des tâches diverses dans
l'espace et vous pensez qu'il y en aura
beaucoup mais je ne sais rien lorsque
général quand on fait des prédictions et
qu'on les regarde avec quelques dizaines
d'années de recul elle s'en faut ce que
vous pensez que les russes ont pu et
très progressivement pour améliorer ce
matériel on voit apparaître de nouveaux
éléments progressivement et les
américains ont pris une approche qui est
différente qui a introduit dans leur vol
habité une très longue suspension dans
laquelle ils ces patients rien et 7 mai
à l'issue de cette période ils vont
disposer et d'un engin qui permet la
récupération de charge très lourde en
même temps que l'envoi dans l'espace de
charge très lourde en orbite basse la
récupération de charge très lourde de
plusieurs tonnes et à cette période de
stagnation relative qui a qui correspond
au développement de cet engin va
probablement succéder et une période de
progrès très rapides à laquelle j'espère
nous serons largement à ceux ci lundi
prochain dans question de temps vous
parlera de la fusée ariane et du
programme spécial rhdp en général qui a
une chance de prendre bientôt une place
importante
je pense entre les cadres dans les
prochaines années mais dès aujourd'hui
ne manquez pas question de temps
question de temps démission de
jean-pierre elkabbach chez louis berio
la mer pour tous il y aura trois volets
premièrement un reportage sur le bateau
de paul et virginie dont on n'a retrouvé
l'épave au large de l'île maurice
deuxièmement un hommage à l'un que la
disparue en mer au début de l'année dans
la course du rhum hommage comprenant une
interview de sa femme
terra cola et troisièmement un débat
avec des spécialistes de la voile comme
eric loizeau qui vient de faire naufrage
dans la course tragique du fastnet
bernard despierre organisateurs du tour
de france à la voile la passion de la
mer présenté par louis blériot
ce soir un peu avant 22 heures
nous parlons maintenant pour terminer de
météo la région rhône-alpes connaît
depuis trois jours des températures
exceptionnellement froides de -5° à -6
degrés en dessous de la moyenne
habituelle du mois il a gelé ambérieu
dans l'ain la neige a fait son
apparition en montagne notamment sur les
pistes de ski de l'alpe d'huez des deux
alpes
la randonnée les expéditions en montagne
ne doivent être entrepris cas les
entreprises espèrent bon qu'avec un
maximum de précautions en raison de la
couche de neige qui dealent afp recouvre
les sommets et la plupart des sentiers
mais j'ai l'impression que le temps
s'améliore un peu demain en effet si la
bretagne la vendée la normandie le
bassin parisien le nord ma foi sur
toutes ces régions il fera gris et frais
avec même des pluies peut être sur les
côtes de la manche
le temps sera bien ensoleillé sur tout
le reste du pays et les températures
seront agréables
si cette tendance continue on va bientôt
parvenir à se croire en été on sera pas
trop tôt à 23 heures hervé claude vous
donnera les dernières informations
demain antennes 2010 présenté par daniel
bilalian
demain soir à 20h si tel est votre choix
nous n'entrerons this bonsoir